عندما أستمع إلى
الموسيقى أشعر بالعديد من الأشياء أشعر
بالسطوع والظلام والدفء والبرودة
لتلك الأصوات
كعازف منفرد موهبته واضحة ولكن
لا يريد العزف بمفرده كان
يحلم دائمًا بالانضمام إلى أوركسترا
حتى الآن.  حلم مستحيل
لأن كيونغ هو أعمى لا يمكنني
الاتصال بالعين ، ولا
يمكنني إلقاء نظرة على إيقاع قائد الأوركسترا
في أوركسترا ، ولم أستطع أبدًا العزف في
مجموعة ،
كل معلمي قلقون من
أنهم قالوا إن حلمي بأن أصبح
عازف إيقاع
صعب
[موسيقى  ]
بالنسبة لك ، تغير كل شيء عندما التقى كيونغ هو
بمصمم الآلات البريطاني
فاهريكان ماتوسيان ، وابتكروا معًا
العصا اللمسية
[الموسيقى
] الإحساس بالمشاعر أساسًا
هو الإحساس بلمسة المجال وفي
حالتنا هو الاهتزاز ،
فإن الهراوة اللمسية هي قائد موصل  الهراوة
التي تستشعر حركة
الموصل
واللاعبين الذين يرتدون العصابات يشعرون بهذه
الحركة على شكل موجات أو نبضات
حول الجسم تقريبًا داخل
الجسم وهذا يعطي  لهم توقيت
الموسيقى
[الموسيقى]
كان العصا بمثابة تغيير في لعبة
كيونغ هو مع
أجهزة اهتزاز يمكن ارتداؤها مربوطة إلى
كاحليه ويمكن أن يقودها موصل والانضمام إلى
مجموعة من الموسيقيين
[موسيقى] من
خلال الاهتزاز الذي يتم توصيله
بواسطة  الجهاز يمكنني أن أشعر كيف
يدق الموصل
بقوة ناعمة
أو طويلة يمكنني أن أشعر بجسدي بما
لا أستطيع رؤيته بشكل
أساسي يمكن للموصل إجراؤه كما يفعل
عادةً
وسوف ينقل العصا هذه
الحركة مباشرة إلى اللاعبين
دون أي مشاكل
[موسيقى]
عندما حصلت أخيرًا على هذا
النموذج الأولي للعمل
وفي المرة الأولى التي استخدمت فيها عصا اللمس ،
كيف شعرت أنني متحمس جدًا
قبل عامين ، كان لدينا حفل موسيقي صغير في
بريستول في المملكة المتحدة
موسيقيون مكفوفون من المملكة المتحدة وكوريا
ورؤية موسيقيين من المملكة المتحدة
وما إلى ذلك  عزف 10 منا
سيمفونية بيتهوفن ، شعرت أن قادة الفرق الموسيقية يضربون دون
أي تأخير في الوقت المناسب
، وتأمل الآلات البشرية في منظمته
أنه إذا تمكنوا من العثور على
الشركاء المناسبين  ستصبح ic baton أصغر حجمًا
وأخف
وزنًا وأرخص سعرًا وبحلول عام 2022 ستكون متاحة
في كل قاعة حفلات في موسيقى مدرسة
الموسيقى ،
تكون الموسيقى عالمية ويجب أن
تعكس المجتمع بأسره ، وإذا نظرت إلى
الأوركسترا اليوم ،
فأنت لا ترى المجتمع ينعكس الآن
مع  هذا
الاختراع الجديد ليس هناك أي عذر
للأوركسترا في جميع أنحاء العالم
لعدم وجود أعضاء ضعاف البصر
في الأوركسترا ،
لذا فقد غيرت هذه التكنولوجيا أحلامك
في حياتك المهنية وما يمكنك تحقيقه
، هذا صحيح ، يمكن لهذا الجهاز أن يفتح إمكانيات جديدة
الآن لدي فرصة  انضمامي إلى
أوركسترا باستخدام عصا اللمس
[الموسيقى]
هذه ، فتحت لي مرحلة جديدة
لمجال عمل جديد
[موسيقى]